[Music]  Jeff Goldblum legend his line is coming  back life finds away Jeff with the open  shirt will it make a comeback in this  film I feel like he'd be game he would  totally today contrary to popular page  that was a wardrobe malfunction pure  accent they filmed damn it and I tried  to pull all the prints of that but that  is one big pilot what about you is most  like a dinosaur  I'm lyrical at times I'm fierce at times  I'm lethal and I punchy  when it comes to trees every girl on my  team like Brice  I love watching them react to Jeff  Goldblum even myself I love he's just  magnetic yeah I met him he gave me a hug  and then he said my my lip mole was a  chocolate pillow mints I'm gonna keep  that forever yeah like you just feel  like this you're just saying he's like  it he's like a snake charmer what did I  do  like yesterday  [Music]